Hallo ihr Lieben! Heute gibt es was persisches,
ich habe mir gedacht: "Es muss mal wieder ein persisches Gericht her!" Wir machen persisches Kebab.
Das ist typisch dass man da zum Beispiel Sumak und Safran rein tut,
aber ich erzähle euch gleich alles ganz in Ruhe.
Ich habe jetzt hier mein Rinderhackfleisch, diesmal habe ich nicht das fettarme genommen.
Ich geb - ich fang direkt an - ich geb da jetzt zuallererst mal Zwiebeln rein und die müsst ihr fein reiben,
das ist ganz wichtig. Und anschließend kommt auch noch Knoblauch dazu.
Als nächstes geben wir den Safran dazu, dafür mörse ich ihn erstmal,
geb da einen Schluck Wasser dazu und dann mit zum Fleisch.
Safran ist bei persischen Gerichten nicht wegzudenken, der ist wirklich sehr, sehr wichtig.
Einerseits hat er Eigengeschmack und andererseits hebt er auch noch den Geschmack
aller Zutaten, die verwendet werden, also probiert's unbedingt aus! Ich gebe jetzt hier noch Salz dazu,
natürlich Pfeffer. Außerdem gehört zum persischen Kebab auch immer
Kurkuma und ganz wichtig, darauf nicht verzichten: Sumak, also Essigbaumgewürz.
Unbedingt mit rein geben und dann schön kneten.
So, jetzt habe ich das Fleisch ungefähr 4min lang geknetet mit den Händen.
Ihr könntet jetzt auch die Bakery Boss nehmen wenn ihr die habt, das macht die auch mit links.
Jetzt müsst ihr das einfach nur noch in den Ofen schieben.
Traditionell ist es so, dass man das grillt auf Spießen aber man will ja nicht jeden Tag grillen.
Deswegen mach ich das jetzt im Ofen. Ihr könntet's sogar in der Pfanne machen.
Dann einfach von beiden Seiten ausbraten, würde sogar auch gehen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier meine Grillschale. Das ist jetzt keine Einweg-Grillschale so wie ihr sie vielleicht kennt.
Das ist eine, die man immer und immer wieder benutzen kann und die nehme ich heute.
Geb da jetzt noch ein Backpapier drauf weil eben auch gleich das Fett vom Fleisch austreten wird.
Einmal draufgeben. So und jetzt einfach ganz schön flach andrücken.
In die kleine Grillschale gebe ich jetzt noch Tomaten und Peperoni und dann grill ich das auch im Backofen.
So das Kebab kommt jetzt bei 200° C Ober- und Unterhitze in den vorgeheizten Backofen
für ca. 20-22min bis es komplett gar ist.
Bei uns gibt's dazu jetzt Reis, ich mach dazu einfach Basmati Reis,
kurz vorher ordentlich abspülen damit keine Stärke mehr enthalten ist. Das Ganze in Öl so ein bisschen anrösten
und mit Wasser auffüllen. Und dann lasst ihr das ganz einfach auf niedriger Stufe
köcheln bis es gar ist. Und weil das eben dazu passt,
mache ich jetzt auch noch so ein bisschen optisch was mit Safran  und natürlich auch geschmacklich.
Dafür nehmt ihr euch jetzt wieder Safran,
tut's in den Mörser und dann kommt da so ein bisschen heißes Wasser mit dazu.
So anschließend färbt ihr einen Teil des Reis einfach mit dem Safranwasser ein
und gebt das auf den weißen Reis und fertig ist es.
Also ich find' das macht auch nochmal optisch was her, sieht einfach schmackhaft aus!
So, da können jetzt auch noch Rosinen dazu, finde ich auch immer ganz lecker.
Oder was ich auch sehr, sehr lecker finde sind generell Beeren,
Goji Beeren, irgendwelche getrockneten Beeren. Müsst ihr einfach mal ausprobieren und-
(H: Oder Nüsse!)
Oder Nüsse! Oh Gott ich liebe Reis mit Nüssen!
Das müssen wir eigentlich mal machen!
Ich werde jetzt ganz kurz zum Ofen und das Kebab rausholen
und dann zeige ich euch, wie ich alles serviere.
So, jetzt dürft ihr euch nicht wundern!
Das Fleisch schrumpft beim Backen wegen des Fettanteils
und jetzt schneidet ihr das einfach in lange Stränge.
Und dann könnt ihr das einfach alles komplett servieren mit den Tomaten,
mit Peperoni, mit Reis und gerne auch noch mit ein bisschen Joghurt.
Und ich mache ganz am Ende auch noch mal ein bisschen Sumak oben drauf.
(H: Boah ich bin SO froh darüber, dass wir das jetzt vor Ramadan gedreht haben)
Jaa!
(H: weil ich das jetzt essen kann!)
Genau!
(H: Das riecht schon so geil!)
Jetzt müsst ihr euch das Ganze ja nur noch schmecken lassen!
Einen guten Appetit, schaut in die Videobeschreibung
natürlich wie immer für alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben.
Ansonsten solltet ihr allerspätestens jetzt meinen Kanal abonnieren
wenn ihr die Ramadan Reihe nicht verpassen möchtet!
Jetzt gibt's den ganzen Monat lang orientalische Rezepte!
Und wenn ihr Vorschläge habt - ein, zwei Tage haben wir noch frei -
schreibt sie mir jetzt hier unten in die Kommentare was ich unbedingt machen soll.
Und dann sehen wir uns bei meinem nächsten Rezept!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!